alright welcome everybody super excited
to be here we have usually done our dell
smv chats via twitter decided we're like
a go video this time around i have to
get your questions and talked about how
you can spring clean your business it's
spring the weather is getting warmer
your time you think about you know what
are the things in your life that you
want to clean up and you got to apply
that to your business too i'm going to
share my five tips to help you spring
clean your business but also the best
part about these usual twitter chats
with now video chats is you guys you
want to get your questions I feel free
to leave it in the child leave in the
comments and as I pull up I'll go
through them and hopefully answer your
questions the next hour you've got me
for one hour so give me your toughest
questions and I'm excited to help you up
so the start so I'm gonna go to the five
tips and i'm going to get to the
questions from you guys the first one
for me is compared to where you were
last year i think it's so easy for
entrepreneurs to get discouraged is it's
a grind you're struggling you don't see
a lot of progress sincerely day to day
but quite often if you look back to
where you were and heard the last year
there's been some considerable growth
and that's an awesome opportunity to
celebrate one of our loyal delos and be
chatters is rishi cup and she has a
youtube channel she kept TV that is just
celebrating its first year coming up and
so this amazing we will look back and
see how much you've accomplished in the
past year but the 22 is Neil's and why
why not and are you things you know I
think the logical advice is awful i just
got to work harder but for me it's also
understanding is this something that you
should actually be doing you know maybe
it's time to take a hard look and think
is this the business i want to be in or
leases hassett i should be doing for me
to get to where I want to go so compare
yourself now to where you were last year
take stock of some of the winds that you
have I think entrepreneurs don't
celebrate enough the victories that
they've had and then also think about
look where you want to go in the next
year and are you going to do the same
things that you did last year
right or are you going to be changing up
your plan to hopefully have more success
number two is productivity it's easy
contra printers to get bogged down by
life by work where everything from the
CEO down to the janitor in our
businesses and so productivity for me
some of the basic start with just gear
right I mean I I plowed through my gear
I I replace a laptop every year and a
half I replace a tablet every year and a
half i replaced a desktop computer every
year and a half to clean my business
usually by the two-year mark i'm at the
point of the gods getting is getting too
slow i need to i need to upgrade it and
just something as simple as that helps
because if you're sitting there on tech
that is really really slow and you want
to you're thinking miles ahead and
you're slow down by your gear um that
really hurts on top of productivity if
you're looking at where are you focusing
is venue I think I'm entrepreneurs have
a hard time staying focused we get
distracted easily you know emails come
in and and you're now focused on
answering that email instead of focus on
the big property that you're supposed to
be focusing on and then also in terms of
kind of steam thinking about how you're
organizing the digital stuff in your
life right how are you organizing your
emails your files you just have things
all over the place it can you organize
them better I'm a big fan of using
software and tools and then we'll get
into it later on in this episode here
talking about some of the things that I
used to help me safer and I'll take a
hard look at how are you is it the best
use of your time right I would always
walk to work thinking what's the best
use of my time today and try to spend as
much time doing the CEO stuff as
possible and as little time as possible
doing the putting out fires the
administrative stuff the stuff that I
have no interest in doing or I will
never be one of the best in the world I
and I think too many entrepreneurs don't
spend enough CEO time they have improved
apart to be enough number three is you
create a really great work environment I
think it runners when you're working at
home are you working in your basement or
garage or you know you don't have an
environment around you you you left the
job to start your own business and
that's exciting but the boss over you
when you don't have people you know kind
of guiding you and telling you what to
do that's a good thing but it's also bad
and that it can be hard to stay
motivated sometimes and if you wanted to
great things you need a great
environment and so it could be aligning
yourself with people and working from a
co-working place it could be even
getting out of the house and going to
work at coffee shop if you're ready how
the business and you're up and running
I'd be looking at you know who are the
people that are on my team if I built
anybody on my team yet what is my office
look lifelike what's around me what's
what's on the on the walls what's on the
cabinets be looking at what am I had
habits and rituals things that you know
if I want to do something great again I
need to be surrounded by greatness and
so do you have the new life and most
entrepreneurs don't we have these
moments of inspiration where we like
maybe you're you're watching this live
chat and you get inspired and the rest
of the day you're off and you're on fire
you're working away and then you wake up
tomorrow and life gets in the way again
and you're not motivated in far and so
part of that is not by accident
happening to come across a chatter you
know in your calendar for once a month
but point of every day starting your day
with something with a with routines with
habits with what's on the wall with what
you do when you first wake up that sets
you up for success instead of randomly
coming across something it's so
important to create an environment that
supports you doing something big number
four is I want you to refresh your
marketing plan I want you to take a
really good look at what you're doing on
the marketing side and is it working and
can you try something new I think even
looking at what we're doing right now
right even even but big companies can
expand and evolve what we're doing now
with with this Twitter chat moving it to
video
or matt is a test right and seemed to
people like it leave in the comments if
you liked the video format about the
interesting to know and so looking at
your marketing plan you know if you
haven't gotten a lot of success yet then
you have to change up your marketing
plan to try new things and I'm not the
guy who goes all-in on these massive big
strategies and hope that they work I'd
much rather test out a lot of different
things do a lot of different small tasks
and see what you get some traction both
in terms of traction from from the
audience like you people care about this
and do you enjoy it like are you having
fun doing this because going out to
networking events can be a great
marketing strategy but if you're really
introverted and you hate book when a
network in advance friends then it's
never going to work out like you can't
force yourself to be somebody who you're
not and need to find the marketing
strategy that's right for you and so it
has encouraged you to start looking at
different ways that you can market your
business this year to get the goals that
you want to achieve and then the last
point was model success this want to
serve me really well my whole life as an
entrepreneur in my first business when I
was struggling and making no money I
almost quit and I told my business
partner that I quit and I I just felt so
worthless that I was making three
hundred dollars a month and could make
my business survive and the turning
point for me was understanding that I'm
not the first guy to try to sell at that
time software is what I was saw the
first guy I try to sell software for
people have done this the answer is
there I used to find people who done it
and model their success and the story
that really turned my business my career
around without a bill gates where he
made partnerships and I started then
making partnerships in my business and I
closed my first partnership for 13 and a
half thousand dollars and guys I may not
sound like a lot of money to you but men
to me he when I'm making three that that
was that was that was some next-level
awesomeness and and most importantly I
had a model that I could then follow I
get in the kit and so look up the great
entrepreneurs look up to Michael down
how he started down and went from zero
to one right I mean it may not be
massively helpful to look at how how
someone like gates ardell makes an extra
million dollars now but 021 how did you
do that these guys are legendary
entrepreneurs there's lessons you can
learn from their success that you don't
have to come up with all the answers
yourself but I think that was the
struggle for me when I was first
starting out I felt like I had to come
up with everything myself and whatever
problem you're going through right now
somebody has already solved it so model
them learn from them the bigger the name
they are the easier it is to find their
stories whether it's what unit up
whether it's reading their book whether
it's finding articles Maggie of them all
those things to be Edmund tours one what
you're trying to do and to people that
you just look up to people that he
respect you know maybe you really love
Oprah Winfrey maybe she's your role
model you know you don't want to be in
the media business but you just love her
there are stories that you can learn
from her there are little lessons you've
been pulled from her success you can
apply to your business even if you're in
a different industry and I think that's
often where a lot of the genius comes is
by doing something different than how it
is and so both of those look to people
who are done exactly what you want to do
and then people who looked up in the
other lessons to your business so those
are the five tips you want to compare to
where you were over last year you want
to improve your productivity you want to
create a great work environment you want
to refresh your marketing plan and you
want a model success to ideally get the
best results so that this spring is
different and better than last spring so
we're gonna get to the questions now I
see a whole bunch of chatter already
happening it's awesome if you have a
question for me we've got what 50
minutes left so leave it in the chat and
I'll go through them one by one we have
a bunch of free questions coming in on
twitter so i want to get to some of
those too but first want to get one that
came in live from j who's asking about
networking and the question was what's
your best tip for meeting like-minded
people that share similar goals so back
to the point about the environment super
important that you sir
with the team of people who are on the
same page as you right not just the
skills right like you know you might be
we get something the typical advices hey
you're we get sales that you're strong
at programming then you be the program
and gold partner up with a sales guy
which is great but you also need to have
similar values into what the mission is
that you're trying to accomplish and and
connecting with people who on the same
mission is one of the hardest and most
important things that you can do as an
entrepreneur the way I do it maybe
differently than you I'm not the guy who
goes out to networking events and
conferences I don't talk to the guy next
to me on here playing and given my
business card and instantly strike up a
chatter much more integrated that way
for me I think what's important is first
understanding what your mission is like
what are you trying to do when you try
to accomplish what's a positive impact
that you want to try to make on the
world and then spreading that and so
whether you're making youtube videos
whether you're active on Twitter whether
you're putting a blog post whether
you're then trying to find other people
who are creating similar content when
you reach out to the person via line
like if you reach out to me and you love
the message of believe when you love
helping entrepreneurs or instantly alive
even if I know ideally I'm cause I going
to read your email and be curious about
your product or service because we're on
the same page and so what you want to
one be clear about what your mission is
and then to start finding people well
and it's not that hard to find them
online find people who are the same
passion as you have a different object
products an ID partner that's what I do
a lot of success in it is my primary
channel to to attract a lot of those
people into my life and super important
next Sandra Abraham's love to know your
hacks for productivity so we talked
about productivity a little bit already
um in terms of hacks some of the things
that have really helped me one chunk in
my time so anything that you do multiple
times
month do once a month multiple times a
week do once a week multiple times per
day do once per day so insanely helpful
you look at something that typically
sucks people's time away like email and
I used to provide myself as the guy who
would respond to email instantly like
you send me an email a minute later you
have a response and I was like I'm doing
a good job as an eye all right like I go
so quickly and then I realized that I
wasn't getting anything big done because
all I was doing was responding to people
on email quickly and preventing me from
getting important stuff done in my
business none of the big tasks that i
had the things that i wanted to go and
accomplish we're getting done and so
chunking my time to the point where i
started with entran emailed twice a day
move down to once a day and now i only
check email once a day from my team and
everybody else i check when i have time
you know i took the subway to get here
in the morning so i pulled up my tablet
and i was answering email on a little
subway and so some time to three days
going to get back and you have to be
okay with that because you're letting go
of some little losses to go after
something big like I'm using that time
instead of answering email during the
day I mean to not come to focus on one
of my big priorities right you're you
have to be willing to give up those
losses and one of the biggest losses
that I lose our media opportunities
because often media reporters are on a
tight deadline and I need to know about
a four o'clock today if you can answer
this for me and that's okay like I'm
comfortable losing those opportunities
because I'm working on something much
much much bigger ah the next thing in
terms of productivity hat for me is I
like 90 minute chunks I find that if I
work in 90 minute chunks it's an ideal
time to get me into something make me
super productive and when I know that
there's a limit like I have to get this
done in 90 minutes it forces me to be
really productive and I don't check
facebook and I'm not on the tablet
looking at my feet you know all that
kind of stuff usual time wasters um and
it's it's a long enough time that you
can get in
something and be massively productive
and so i'll do a 90-minute chomping in a
15 minute break and dining with a chunky
15 minute break another break I try to
do something not on the computer I spend
a lot of my time either in front of the
camera or in front of the computer and
so if it's a difficult of a work day
then I'll be off walking around or you
know just doing some exercise to get my
eye off of the computer the time roof
expenditure and then a latte is so the
Thursday today's Thursday recording this
there's it my public facing day thursday
i'm doing my interviews i'm doing
hangouts i'm on periscope I do there are
del s and B chats it's always public
facing day wednesday i spend the whole
day in studio doing video tuesday i
spend the whole day doing my book monday
spend the whole day working on my
dancing business and so having those
days chunked out I find massively
productive for me and get way more done
than I used to so hopefully that helps
that be curious what your productivity
hacks are everybody watching live so you
can help each other out some of the top
things that you guys are going coming
out next up Jared if you're an artist
under in the process of leaving your
regular job to become a living artist
you concentrate more on branding your
work or more in creating your work for
these kinds of questions I love
embracing the genius of the end because
you can't just do one or the other it's
both what what I would try to do is one
I would try to be in a job where I'm
gonna learn right like I'm not the guy
who says quit your job going on your
business and hopefully it works out you
know burn the boats I'd like having a
job and doing your business part time on
the side the caveat there is I want you
to have a job where you're going to
learn I want you to have a job where
ideally if you're an artist you're
working for another artist or you
working for an art studio are you
working for somebody that you're
learning from and not some huge company
ideally a 10-person company or less that
you can learn from and get us close
entrepreneur founder is possible to
learn some of their skills that they
learn and your such and getting paid to
learn right and normally universe if you
pay to go learn here you're getting paid
to learn to make mistakes you're getting
paid to make industry connections and
then do your business on the side and so
I don't know what your job is but I
would try to find one where you are
learning um then you're trying to apply
everything that you learn to your own
business right in terms of branding
yourself in terms of creating the
product like you need both right if you
if all you're doing is creating product
you're creating art and you don't tell
anybody about it then you're never going
to sell anything but if all you're doing
is creating your brand you don't create
the art then you're not gonna give me a
gigs either see you need to have both um
anything recognizing that I would try to
I would try to chunk my time to make me
spend time on both because it could be
hard at least for me when I'm writing my
book it's hard for me to be distracted
by anything else I mean that's a that's
a creative process for me that's my art
when I'm making videos that's my art I
can't I can't be thinking about anything
else besides making that video and so if
I were you and you're working at night I
might try to do you know monday tuesday
wednesday night working on my art
thursday friday night working on my
brand and the promotion and so when you
come home thursday night you know i'm
working on my my company now i'm working
on my exposure and put on that business
hat i think you'll be more successful
doing that and trying to manage both at
the same time experiment with Middle
East because it's really helped me in my
creative process next MO same of the
name o same how do you free up your
mental energy that's an awesome question
I think entrepreneurs just do too much I
think entrepreneurs don't allow time to
breathe if you think about when you get
most of your creative ideas it's almost
never when you're sitting there at the
office usually doing something right
you're on vacation you're in the shower
you're walking the dog you're eating
breakfast something
you need you need down time to give you
creativity and so for me I factor in
personal stuff into my schedule just as
much as I do the business stuff so when
I'm making my 90 minute chunks and I'm
plotting up my calendar all of the
personal stuff that I want to do whether
it's spend time with my wife whether
it's salsa dancing whether it's you know
we're gonna we're going to take eight in
the Disney World or whatever it is it's
all factored into the schedule and I
treat them as importantly as I would a
business meeting right I think it's easy
for people to say okay that's my
personal time but then they just let
business bleed into it because you have
some deadlines or some meeting came up
I'm treated like an important business
meeting I think you need you need the
downtime to be creative so for me that's
how I do it uh I have hobbies you know I
have a life outside of my company I
still work really hard and when I'm
working is really focused and productive
but I think you need to create some
space for yourself if you want a free up
duck time to have that mental energy and
the creativity new business from Kevin
do you believe social media is a tool
for business absolutely what do I mean
what are we doing right now we're using
social media we're doing business right
ever how answering your questions
hopefully you're using some of these to
help you grow and learn and get better
um I love social media I think it
depends on your personality and it
depends on you know depends on your
style my default is to get on social
make videos respond to people i love the
comments like I I would rather spend in
an hour here talking to you 50 minutes
answering your questions and talk and
you than me going off and going on a
presentation for an hour because I find
value in knowing that I'm helping people
with their specific questions so if
you're doing any kind of business we
want to
here's the thing I think too many
entrepreneurs get on social because they
think it's a marketing strategy because
somebody told them need to get on social
and they get out there and they you know
spam spam their products and just spam
their events and i'm not actually
offering any value and that's a
challenge where you have to actually
care about your audience at your
building if you don't care about them
there's no way they're going to care
about you get the show that you care of
it first and back to jay's question
earlier about how to attract like-minded
people you know you want to attract
like-minded customers like wine and
suppliers like-minded investors
like-minded friends to your business and
the easiest way to do that is to spread
through social media right talk about
your mission talk about you staying for
but something that's inspiring out there
that people will cling on to and feel
moved by I'm a huge fan I you know my
business would look a lot different
social media didn't exist so I'm
extremely grateful for it and I don't
want to say this necessarily for
everyone but it's definitely worth
exploring back to our third point about
it's our fourth point about refreshing
marketing times the top of the show
definitely worth exploring if you
haven't already and you kind of already
are like you ask a question you already
and social even even the comments that
are happening now in a rock with the
other part of this live stream right if
you provide value right if you help
somebody else out there probably gonna
check you out they're going to go check
out your screen you're going to check
out what your business all about there's
a fit needed to hire you right but it
all comes from providing that value up
front next Winston bromley in periscope
how can you target ideal customers
that's a tough one for me i'm not a huge
periscope er um i think if you're going
to be targeting people with with twitter
and periscope is a video version of
twitter you'd be looking at local so you
can search your people who are finding
you know so if i have a salsa dancing
business in Toronto right I could look
up any time somebody types salsa with an
X mile radius of my studio in Toronto
and I could respond to that right and I
could make
video reply to working great a periscope
around it I think with periscope to the
other great thing is you can hop on to
other people screams and provide value
right leave some comments show something
love it benefits one the people who are
putting out the content right like if I
was doing a daily scope and the same
people kept coming back over and over
and over and over again then I would be
curious about what their business was
you know I'd be curious what they're
upside want to check them out if they're
on periscope I want to follow them I
want to see if I can provide value
somehow the generates curiosity that on
top of the other people in the chat and
so I'd be trying to find streams that
are targeted to your interest that your
customers are likely to be in right so
if it's a slope of some high school kid
reading Shakespeare on his backyard
porch you know that's why not going to
be a lot of value if you're trying to be
an entrepreneur but if you're if you
want advice to be an entrepreneur you
want to sell the entrepreneurs this is a
great one to be on and you want to be
engaging active in the chat because
everybody watching is entrepreneurs to
write those are all potential customers
for you that you'll need the hard sound
saying go check out my site but by
providing value there people will want
to check you out next questions are
insane Rishi Rishi I don't know if you
were here at the start but we gave a
shout out to the one-year anniversary of
Rishi cup DV on YouTube congratulations
a long time loyal della sand beach at
your I feel like part of spring cleaning
in your business is reevaluate where you
invest your time energy and resources
and absolutely and we talked a little
bit about that at the start I just where
you focus your time I think a lot of
times entrepreneurs stick with something
for too long you get now you get an idea
from somebody maybe I say get on social
media and try it out and then you get on
and you're trying and you're trying it
and try and use doing the same thing
over and over and over again and you're
not getting the results because you
haven't made any tweaks I often find
that the the results that have really
been created in my business has been
taking advice and then tweaking it I
think about when I was at my agency
alright still at the agency but what is
doing media training my my trainer would
always give me advice which I could
never quite get like it was good advice
but I always had to tweak it for myself
so just like when you're modeling
success you can't do the exact same
thing that somebody else did but you've
been usually tweak it to make it work
for your business and I think
entrepreneurs is typically focus on the
wrong things and for too long and don't
do enough experiments and aren't
constantly trying to invigorate and
change what they're up to and stretch
your comfort zone so I'm mentoring a
number of entrepreneurs right now and
one of the things that comes up over and
over and over and over again is how they
use in your time you know they'll spend
half an hour writing some email to
somebody that is super low leverage
where they could be spending it
somewhere else something is a lot higher
priority this has been on your list for
three weeks that hasn't gotten done and
you're spending your time doing these
tiny little tasks I mean physical tasks
are easy maybe because that big task is
scary you know but you're just focused
on the wrong thing and I think it's
pivotal for entrepreneurs at least every
spring to be evaluating where you're
spending your time what your schedule
looks like for me I look at my schedule
probably at least once a month and look
at where am i spending my time and
making slight tweaks and adjustments
whenever something feels a little off
what am I feeling too stressed out
there's too much work happening that I
know I need to change my schedule around
somehow to make time for next Alan
Stuart where do you find inspiration for
the content you put online and how do
you stay motivated to do it when you're
so busy that's a great question I think
for the content most of the content that
I put up comes from from you guys comes
from recommendation suggest 10 series
that I have it's all from suggestions
from the audience
out of twelve hundred plus suggestions
with more suggestions and I have time to
do look at this session right now right
you know I talk for ten minutes and then
we're doing 50 minutes of Q&A and all
the content comes from you guys asking
questions and so I would try to involve
your audience as much as possible know
what kind of content you're creating
asking for things but then also do
things that you're you're passionate
about one of the things that was an
important lesson for me in creating
content was that whenever you're in the
moment you want to try to report it I
never did one video not too long ago
where I was walking home I was upset at
something and so just took a my tablet
and started feeling myself and the
quality is super bad you know it's super
dark outside really poor lighting any
any videography look at that and just
cringe but the content was great because
I was excited and passionate and angry
about it and so whenever you're in that
moment you want to try to report it and
so you create you create the creating
creep because it's something you feel
needs to be created a a lot of the
questions that come up will often turn
into bigger pieces because I have more
to say I want to help and so it was a
combination of one at least for my
channel my stuff that I put up
combination of one comment and to just
what i want to say what I feel of the
world needs and that's my lens that I
see the world and then in terms of
second part was how do you stay
motivated I think hung find it again
that was Alan how do you see motivated
you guys keep me motivated you know I
think this is part of creating the
environment for greatness that we talked
about in point three at the top one of
the things I do every day every day I
load my youtube comments unload my
social media comments and seeing people
writing to say Evan you know this video
helped me keep going Evan thank you so
much like just seeing that stuff coming
daily just makes you want to do it more
it motivates me makes
like the work that I'm doing matters and
I think it's important for any
entrepreneur to feel like the things
that you're doing matter to people
before I had a big social media audience
I used to do presentations and do
speeches and I would find that just
after a speech the next we could be on
my own high like bra really helped all
those people now you've got a great buzz
from the room and then falls back to
place that i would i would lose that
energy so what I would do was I took
samples of all the full the people gave
him and how it really helped them and I
would put that into a powerpoint that I
watched every morning and that helped
remind myself that what I was doing
support and as an entrepreneur you may
find that to it when you really you feel
really rewarded like I need to know what
I'm doing is good like it really helps
people and just that one in traction can
keep you going for another week you know
are never fun I'm soon as i'm yours'
important but you're printing goals but
I'll insanely fortunate now with such a
following that it's new every day like I
can keep up we get we get hundreds of
comments every day across social
channels which is amazing but that's how
I stay motivated inspires is you guys
give me great feedback um and then I
think to the model and success that
really helps me and looking at people
who've done really great things in
researching stories every day and
starting my day with that too I helped
me feel like you know what I'm doing
what I've done so far is nothing
compared to what i want to do what
others have done and seeing other people
doing great things on a daily basis
makes me want to reach for more so
that's where having aspirational role
models can really help you because if
you really love Oprah and you look at
what she's doing and then you look at
your life and you look at your friends
around you they may all be saying oh
you've done such a great job Liam
congratulations starting
business and there's nobody pushing to
say yeah but you could do way more like
good job so far but you could be up here
you're still playing in the minor
leagues and so for me that's what those
those videos and stories help me do
question from parras MJ power sam dekker
book pronounce that ok what can I do in
a month that can improve my financial
status love this this is a lot of lamb
okay so if you look at them making my
and value what an amazing a lot of money
gotta provide a lot about it you want to
make a lot of money quickly go to
provide a lot of value quickly the
challenge then becomes can you actually
provide that value people quickly in a a
month that you can provide that kind of
value to and what would the value be a
lot of times people can provide the
value yet and you need to get better and
you need to learn I hate having to be to
be forced to be in a situation where you
need to make money some people thrive on
to that by the way this is just my own
personal bias some people they have to
go ill and they have to burn the boats
they have to have no backup plan and
just go for it I don't like that because
I feel it forces you to do stupid things
sometimes and take on bad clients and do
bad deals which can hurt you in the
short term and in potential long-term if
money is an absolute short-term
necessity and you're really struggling
this might be counterintuitive but back
in earlier point I've been looking at
getting a job even if it's part time
where I could learn where could learn
from someone who's going to teach me
who's going to make me better if you're
looking at just growing your business so
and how can i make money in the next
month the fastest way to do it is
through just what I hit with my business
struggling and making cleaner dollars a
month and I landed my 13 and five
thousand dollar deal it's just some
partnerships so i'll be looking at who
can you ally yourself with who already
has your car
the audience and how can you work with
them so not a direct competitor but some
products or services how can you phone
them up well for coffee introduce
yourself to them and I quite email
whatever it is to find a way that you
might people to work together to have
them introduce you to their audience
it's the fastest way to grow the
business but I hate when it's desperate
as opposed to do bad deals how do you
define a couple of things that
absolutely didn't produce expected
results in the past here and evaluate
whether or not they're still part of
your business and if so why I let me
take a different approach on this uh the
way that I had filled little business
I'm I'm a great starter I know often to
build something up to the point pretty
testing out numbers of numbers of
different projects and most of them
don't go anywhere most of them fail most
of them was like a week of energy and
then it stops because I lose the energy
for i think it's it's a very dangerous
part in a company when you've lost
energy for something you've lost passion
for something and you're still trying to
find a way to make the work it's just
usually a recipe for failure and so when
i find myself at that point when i'm
certain off a project and i'm super
excited about it and then I'll lose the
energy at that point I start to think
okay is it at the point yet where I can
give this off to somebody and they can
run with it or usually sometimes it is
but usually it's not and then it is
dropping the belly and side of the boat
I think too many entrepreneurs hang on
for too long they end up making a box
for themselves and stop innovating and
following things that they're excited
about I think too many entrepreneurs
don't realize that they grow too
typically when you start a business you
are really excited about it great you're
thinking about is unique and innovative
things to do when you create your first
product service
you start to grow as a human being you
know you change you grow you learn new
things you have different interests but
as you grow your business stays on the
same line that it was and you become
less and less interested in what you
were doing you become more and more
disenfranchised with your business
because it no longer reflects who you
are anymore that's a big problem you
need to learn and adapt and grow your
business as you grow as a person and
bring that into your company and if you
can and and that's the time other this
is somebody else it's not add that
dropping out because you will not have a
lot I was it sad doing it you I and that
excitement can last year's class day
likes months no I still love making my
videos I've had my youtube channel for I
don't know how many years I still love
doing it but if wednesday afternoon
which is my youtube day I feel more into
studio and uh I gotta go make youtube
videos today that's the day that I
stopped because my quality will drop my
interest levels dropped and be better
for me to go out to do something that I
am excited though fortunately I'm not
close to there yet but I think that's
what you need to take stock up people
only look at the logic they only look at
the numbers but they don't look at where
their emotional energy is going and
recognizing that you'll never do
anything great unless you have free
passion for it questions and steam how
do you freshen up your software and
technology what types of tech invest
with upgrades have the biggest impact
for entrepreneurs great question I
talked to this at the start about some
of the text that i use and how i always
need to upgrade it i think the great
thing about being an entrepreneur is you
can do so much on your own now if you
have the right tack you don't need to
have a million dollars in funding to
start a business anymore you can start
out of your basement right you can start
out of your home office you can start
with just you can set with a laptop
right that's it
business um i think for me I use I use a
laptop I use it that's my name is a
tablet and I'm always upgrading their
place and done as soon as I am you know
on my tablet on my laptop and it's
getting slow and I'm feeling like I'm
losing productivity right I have 90
minute chunks to get my stuff done I
can't lose 15 of it because I'm waiting
for my computer to reboot right and
waiting for her whatever program you
know photoshop to rent or something
because Mecca so that usually happens
around a year and a half and then the
next half here I see how much of a
struggle it is to me before I upgrade
but constantly upgrading the laptop to
tablet and and my my computer at home I
think depending on your lifestyle you
know I try to I do most of my work from
a home office and I have a monitor to
dual monitor setup with the computer and
then I use a laptop which is usually
pretty light doesn't need to be a
computer replacement and then I use a
tablet to do email and on-the-go stuff I
think there's a lot of missed
opportunities like I'm writing my subway
down here that's why was there an email
i'm standing in line at the government
office to get my license plate renewed
you know pull up the tab will insert
into an email you need a lot of stuff
done um in terms of freshen up your
personal workspace i think it's also
about that's the tech side i think it's
also about having environment that you
love like what's around you right what's
on the walls I for example i thinkI
fluorescent lighting when I had to when
I got my office I ripped out all the
flush of lighting when I when I took
over at trying to dance salsa I took out
I ripped out all the fluorescent
lighting $20,000 and put in pot lights
and put in LEDs because it drives me
nuts you know if I'm in that kind of
environment with too long we'll start to
get a headache and i'll set the crash
some people like to you have to look
outside like if you're in a if you're
indoors all the time you can't have a
window to the outside you go nice that's
important but paying attention to your
energy level is important but also you
know do you put posters up on the wall
that
fire you you have pictures of your
family does that inspire you do you have
books that you could you know put in
range that you want to remind yourself
of some of the messages in those books
that inspires you letters and
testimonials from your customers saying
what an important job you did all of
that is super important and so you you
don't want to have a just stale hospital
like environment you want to have one
that you feel comfortable in and
inspired in and that's different for
everybody but one of the first things I
did at Toronto dance also just as an
example it said told you ripped up the
lighting um we also put a tree on the
wall because the Themis family at TDs
and so we put it with you a tree a
family tree and all the leaves our
pictures of the instructors are helpers
at the school and I got a local artist
to create a big family sign in our font
that went above it and it adds to the
space and it's not just a cold dense
video but it adds warmth and human
element to it and inspires people who
walk in there and go dancing and so you
need to have that in as much of the
spaces that you hang out in as possible
in your home space in you know the
coffee shops you go to in your workspace
the more time you spend in a great
environment the more great things you do
the more time you spend in crappy
environments the less great stuff you're
going to do um so find out the things
that work for you Jane what do you think
are the best tangible forms of marketing
t-shirts stickers teachings etc that's
an interesting one um for me I think a
lot of the stuff is a lot of the swag
stuff is crap people don't really use it
much I i think i think that the ones
that make a difference are where you can
get on an influencer screen with
something meaningful important to them
if i was going to approach this i would
try to find something that you know i
want it i don't want to get in front of
a million people with a keychain that
the
gonna throw away I want to get in find
out someone really important was
something that means something to them
right so you know if I'm a big Steve
Wozniak fan then maybe you get me a
Steve Wozniak signed baseball because I
like baseball too with your logo on the
back or something or like something
meaningful so some people love fashion
right some people really love fashion
and they talk about it on their YouTube
channels in the we're on instagram and
the tweetup pictures they're not just
going to put some random t-shirt on that
you bought for five dollars and you know
I earned your logo on right they're
going to put something on that they love
right so it's got to be unique and
different it's about knowing who your
audience is and it's it's never been
easier right any big name is on Twitter
Instagram you can find out some of their
interests and you can create something
that is a super helpful and targeted
tutorials what they want so I don't know
that it matters so much where there's a
t-shirt or magnet or a you know a pen I
think it's more just tying into the
influencer that you're trying to target
and giving them something that's
meaningful to them right um that's how
it'll put you that's a cool question I
don't think I've been asset before like
I'm sharing I stepped back and looked
over my business I'm going to start with
a new structure / daily schedule and a
complete business plan any comment so
awesome ah that's what spring cleaning
is all about you know take a fresh look
and start rescheduling everything around
I think the most important thing for me
when creating my schedule is putting the
big things in first so I try to plan my
day someone needs a certain day Tuesday
certain day we talked about already on
the stream I what are the important
things that need to happen in your
business and in your life and make time
for them and then everything else will
find its way in but if you don't make
time for those big things then they're
never going to get it right and the
class is the you know there's a
who's the glass and you have rock sand
and water to come the glass if you put
in the water first and in the same later
and the rocks last the rocks wouldn't
fit but the big boxing first then the
sand fills in and then the water fills
in the rest of the space everything
manages the fifth same thing happens in
your life in your business if all you're
doing is the little things and chews up
your time you never feel like you have
time to do the big things where you have
to chunk off time and I would include on
your schedule by the way 90 minutes of
CEO time that's big picture stuff
uninterruptedly focus on growing your
business earlier in the day and then the
other little things will find their
space you will always find time to make
those happen but plot those up on your
schedule it's an exciting time that's
what sprinkling is all about to be my
advice to you Rishi as your business
grows can you so can the opportunity to
invest in yourself collaborate build
alliances and so on my question is
someone who gets so many invitations to
invest yourself and lots of places how
do you personally decide which
opportunities clouds allows you to say
yes or no to things maybe like most
things I have a strange answer for this
one for me it's it's always about the
passion I've done collapse most of the
clouds I've done with people who have
tiny footprints in the social media
world because I really love their energy
in their vibe I think the common the
default answer most people would give
would say okay well you know black and
white identify who the top people are
and go out and work with them and yes
it's important but for me the energy has
to be there and the alignment has to be
there and so if you look at most of the
collabs that I do usually on a Thursday
afternoon on my channel uh there there
with people who don't have any kind of
following or really small following or
that social media isn't their thing I
just like what they're trying to do and
I'm trying to give them more exposure
really I'm just mostly thinking about
the
audience like will you guys find value
in this and will this be a good half an
hour or an hour like we'll just be a
good well I feel happy at the end of
this well I get energy from it and it
always seems to find a way to work out
without an direct ass like it's not hey
you can come on my channel if you do XYZ
for me that never happens um but it
always everything always seems to work
out and so um that's maybe really let me
sound like really fun but new middle
Tonya I like to know I would like to
know to utilize social media to promote
my business outside of Facebook I pretty
much know and use facebook i would like
to tap into other meetings um cool so I
don't know what you're selling Tanya
facebook is great for some things but
maybe not so great for other things the
beauty about Facebook if you're doing it
right is the geo-targeting you know you
can find you know single model of Justin
Bieber and play basketball games in you
can tap into those people who wanted to
that was your target audience um i would
i would instead of focusing on the
medium first i would think about what
your strengths are because there's a
skill set in each of different mediums I
you know if you love doing video if
you're great on camera or if you want to
be great on camera you want to learn
think you could you can be a star on
camera then you want to be on YouTube
right and you want to start get into
snapchat and maybe do some periscopes if
you're better writing then you are a
video then you want to be a blogger and
you want to try to write in magazines
and online publications and get your
words out you can you can be really
successful on twitter by shortening down
your message and getting the tight um I
think there are some mediums that might
skew more to an audience or others you
know um like snapchat is still heavily
young audience if you're trying to
target 13 18 year olds you want to be on
snapchat but if you're going mainstream
then you can find an audience in
any of them any meetings right like
youtube is so big that everybody's on
YouTube you can find a niche if you're a
gamer you find your niche to notch Mary
find your niche and your beauty you can
find your niche but you have to want to
be good at video to make it happen so it
put the self-audit of your skills figure
what you're really good at and and and
where you want to grow and when you want
to get better at and depending on that
answer your next steps lineup I also
wouldn't discount facebook like to say
you've had success on facebook and now
you're ready to move on you can probably
go way deeper in facebook you can build
a huge business just off of facebook and
if you've already had some success there
then i wouldn't knows a question earlier
freeing the pre-chat about a guy wanted
to move to a new city expand his
business to a new city is having some
success in one city wanted to move to
another one I and my default answer was
well why don't you do more in your
current city like why you obsessed with
going to the next city where you haven't
tapped out what you're doing right now
this probably sell a lot more you can do
on Facebook this is a self challenge
that or think about whether you might
get to do more when you're in five home
before expanding um from crammed mail
I'm considering getting into social but
my concern is privacy how do you keep
private life private while still being
authentic and social that's a great
question I think everybody has their own
boundaries um mine at the start was I
didn't think anybody cared about my
social private life like who cares when
I didn't get on social to start that I
thought Twitter was stupid people
posting what they ate for lunch and
about their cat and I don't care about
it this stuff um I'm running a business
I don't think anybody cared about what
I'm eating for lunch uh I think for me
what helped and again you have to find
your own criteria but for me I I'm
pretty open about sharing things about
myself when I feel like it can help
other people I think that by sharing
your story uh it can be it serves as a
role model for others to follow it
serves as potentially inspiration for
others to follow again how
exception wait your point right so I you
know by me talking about how is making
three hundred dollars a month I can
relate to you guys who are struggling
and starting up and don't know you know
where to go to get your next meal from I
was there where I draw the line is
telling other people's stories you know
I don't talk a lot about my wife unless
she's with me on camera and she's been
in a lot of the episodes my parents are
super private people and so I never
talked about them you know I think they
were in one video maybe my book video
but I never talk about what they're
doing and never talk about what they're
up to you know only that you know
believe came from them and and just some
of their parenting skills and stories
from early on in my life but but they're
super private int I respect that I think
that's for me easier um to have to drive
your own line but I don't I don't want
to drag somebody into the conversation
doesn't want to be in the conversation
in addition to recognizing that by
sharing your story and being vulnerable
and seeing what's on your mind it can
help the person that you're talking to
get to where they need to go faster it
adds credibility for you and adds
authority for you and it helps them like
by telling your story that's what a lot
of much ferns and make a mistake like oh
it's not about me I don't have a huge
ego I don't want this whole thing to be
about me it's not about you it's about
them like if I can read the bio on your
page and it inspires me like why did you
start this company your stories your
competitive and it just how do you stand
out against the big guys are we going to
buy from you when I can buy from a big
company the only reason would be if you
have a cheaper price because the bigger
company has reputation in history and
years of product uh the other reason
though then becomes your stories like i
want to buy to you because i feel like
you care i feel like i like you i know
you i trust you and so you have to share
to get that story out and it
it's about helping them make a decision
not about you saying how good you are
we're wrapping up we're tempering one
more question we'll see see how quickly
I can talk Vincent an awesome session my
voice is getting getting dry they're
gonna have some coffee soon um question
from a cabal what books should I read so
that's a pretty broad question I have a
video on my favorite books for
entrepreneurs it's in my newsletter if
you guys are on the newsletter my
favorite book I've two favorite books of
all time the first is the 4-hour
workweek for ten Paris which is highly
relevant is pretty a lot more productive
I don't agree with the tenant of that he
proposes in there of having a muse
having a business just to make money I
think you have a business to put your
passion into but it's still a super
helpful book that that got me on my path
that the outsourcing and delegating
building a team and really honing in on
my productivity the second one is a book
called radicals and visionaries which is
not available anymore it's out of print
and it's somebody said is on ebay per
thousand dollars or something but maybe
you can get a cheaper version that was
basically uh famous entrepreneur stories
in three pages so it's a book of all the
famous entrepreneurs like this thick and
these entrepreneurs are sharing you know
things that work for them in three to
four pages I used to look at that every
morning talk about having an environment
for greatness I used to read one story
every morning to get a little bit of
Oprah you know pixie dust on me to
hopefully bring some of that in and off
and being successful for the day now I
think this is a lot of other options in
that you can you can find videos is so
many great YouTube channels so many
blogs there's a lot more options than
when I was young and gettin started what
I'm eating now is onward by Howard
Schultz whose a/c unit go round three of
starbucks which is an awesome book about
how he left starbucks and then came back
to it and turned it around because it
started to decline so if you're trying
to build a business around
in value so solid book to read but I'm
curious to what books you guys are
reading or what books you have to read
and leave them comments below and i
might go check some of them out we're
gonna have a email Michael Gerber is
another great both Brian creases written
a whole bunch of great books but I'm
looking for our next book recommendation
for when I'm done onward so leave them
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching uh this has been
amazing this is our very first del SMB
chat video mode uh just as a reminder to
all you guys if you check out the dell
SMBC a twitter handle we're gonna have
some updates there including some coupon
codes if you guys are looking at buying
your next tech gear w some codes give it
away there so you guys are asking what
we're using here this is a dell latitude
7000 of the 13 inch version of it so
super light and easy affordable pretty
awesome so thank you guys so much for
watching you can follow me on twitter
you can follow the dell SMB handle on
twitter as well and let us know you
think of this chat if you should do more
in video format and we'll take it back
soak up the wisdom and so we do for the
next round that's all I got continue to
believe and we'll see you soon